welcome to free code camp I'm commander
candy of coding commanders and today I'm
gonna teach you all about logic logic is
the foundation for all computer
programming so the better you're able to
understand logic the better and faster
you're gonna be able to pick up and
learn any programming language or
encounter any programming endeavour
introduction to logic for programmers
propositional logic you'll find
reference materials and homework at
coding commander's comm slash logic dot
PHP mathematics science and computer
programming all are based on logical
reasoning what logic does is it defines
a set of rules if we want to be able to
sign typically or exactly determine
something we need rules define to make
sure we're all measuring by the same
standards to make sure that if I say
this is a cup cup means the same thing
to you that it means to me and at the
end of the day we use logic to determine
whether things are valid or invalid true
or false if you're gonna be doing
computer programming especially if you
plan on doing business logic building
enterprise applications you know working
for a company it's a lot of validation a
lot of true or false especially on the
back end I've worked with like PHP
nodejs sequel and a lot of what I do
when I'm hired by somebody is validation
is this valid or isn't this is it true
or is it false if you really think about
it at the end of the day just about
anything can be boiled down to true or
false for example say you're taking a
multiple-choice test and the question is
four plus four it's multiple choice your
options are two four six eight
now we're smart mathematicians we know
four plus four equals eight right but
even though that's open-ended that's not
a true/false question we could break the
problem down to four two or false
questions right
four plus four equal to false does four
plus four equal four false
does four plus four equals six false
does four plus four equal eight true and
because that's true that's what we're
gonna select as our answer today we're
gonna cover propositional logic that's
the basic building block of logic it's a
way for us to determine whether things
are valid or invalid you may also hear
it referred to as statement logic
because you can basically think of a
proposition as a statement for example I
have blonde and red hair today that
statement is true propositional logic
allows us to evaluate whether things are
true or false
based on certain conditions this is
sound familiar in computer programming
if statements aren't your rectly derived
from propositional logic and in this
video we're going to learn how remember
logic is all about defined rules so
first things first let's properly define
a proposition a proposition is a
statement it has a truth value that
means it's either true or false it's not
equal to jellybeans it's not equal to
564 it's gonna be true or false and a
proposition can only have one single
truth value so it can't be true or false
it has to be either true or false so
let's look at some statements and
determine if their propositions are not
the first one
commander candy is 4 foot 11 is that a
statement yes
does it evaluate true or false yes and
it can only have one single value I'm
either 4 foot 11 or I'm not 4 foot 11 so
yay commander candy is 4 foot 11 is a
proposition by the way this statement is
true
commander candy is a halfling on 4 foot
11
what is your favorite flavor is that a
statement yes
does it evaluate true or false no this
is not a proposition whatever your
flavor might be chocolate vanilla
strawberry mocha banana mango it's not
true or false next X plus y equals 36 is
that a statement yes
does it evaluate true or false yes
either X plus y is 36 or X plus y isn't
36 but it doesn't have a single value
depending on the values of x and y it
could be true or false so uh this is not
a proposition the better you are at
logic the better you're going to be at
breaking down those complicated problems
that we encounter as programmers if you
can get it broken down to its basic
building blocks is this true or false is
this true or false you can solve just
about any problem there is we can
combine propositions in order to solve
more complicated problems in order to do
say we're going to use variables such as
PQRS X Y Z we're going to use logical
operators things like an and/or we're
gonna learn some others and we're also
going to use comparison operators like
less than greater than equal to not
equal to less than or equal to we'll go
over some of those as well now let's
talk notation okay let's look at an
example we're gonna start with two
statements P and Q let's let P equal
Sally is 42 and we're like Q equal Lynda
is 36 now let's look at some ways to
compare these two statements P and Q we
could do P and Q we can do P or Q
there's also comparisons like exclusive
implication by conditional in order to
evaluate if these statements are true or
false we're going to use something
called a truth table truth tables
consist of multiple columns there's
going to be a column for each statement
or variable and then there's going to be
a column for what we're trying to
evaluate in a scenario like this where
we have two statements or two variables
there's gonna be four possibilities if
Sally is 42 Linda can either be 36 or
not be 36 so if P is true Q can be true
or false
and if P's false Q can be true or false
as well
if Sally isn't 42 Linda can still be or
not be 36 so let's first look at and
Sally is 42 and Linda is 36 that means
both those statements are true both P is
true and Q is true so there's only one
possibility that will make the statement
true and that's if piece true and Q's
true if there's any false going on there
the whole thing's gonna evaluate is
false next we have or Sally is 42 or
Linda is 36 with or P and cubed they
don't both have to be true just one of
them has to be true if just one of them
is true then the statement P or Q is
going to be true with or they don't both
have to be true just one has to be true
so Sally can be 42 Orland that can be 36
P or Q so if there's any truth going on
here the statements can evaluate is true
if Sally is 42 it's gonna be true if
Glen is 36 it's gonna be true but they
don't both have to be telling the truth
mm-hmm so there's gonna be three
possibilities of truth here the only way
that P or Q is gonna evaluate false is
if both P and Q are false next let's
talk about exclusive that means P can be
true q can be true but they can't both
be true so if Sally is 42 its going to
evaluate true if Linda is 36 its gonna
evaluate true but its Sally's 42 and
Linda's 36 it's not gonna evaluate true
if Sally isn't 42 and Linda isn't 36
it's not gonna value a true you need
exactly one true in one false there's
going to be two scenarios to evaluate as
true now let's look at implication
implication is going to read if P then Q
P is what we call the hypothesis and Q
is the conclusion this is a conditional
statement you know like our if
statements and computer programming
those are implication so let's look at
implication if Sally is 42 then Lynda is
36
if Sally is telling the truth and
lenders telling the truth then the
statements true if Sally is telling the
truth and Linda's aligned then the
statement is false
if Sally is lying then it doesn't really
matter if slin de telling the truth or
lying it could still be true because it
has nothing to do with Linda at that
point there's only a condition applied
here if Sally is 42 if Sally lied and
you know it doesn't really matter
anymore anyway now let's look at by
conditional that reads P if and only if
cubed another way to write that is the F
with 2's and this statement is gonna
have the same truth value as P implies Q
and 2 implies P saying it goes in both
directions
so basically if Sally is telling the
truth and Linda's telling the truth this
is going to evaluate true if they're
both lying it's still going to value a
true but if one's telling the truth and
one's lying no matter which direction
it's going in it's filled and evaluate
false and now let's just touch on
negation negation you might see ever in
any of these ways like negative 6 that's
negating sex it's the opposite not it
means like not pee that's how you would
read that or the opposite of pee so
basically if P is true not pees gonna be
false if P is false not P is gonna be
true now we're gonna look at some of our
comparison operators less than greater
than less than or equal to greater than
or equal to not equal to these are some
comparisons there's also like identical
if you're familiar in computer
programming like you have like three
equal signs
these are comparison operators these are
ways that we can compare numbers and we
use these often in our conditional
statements okay let's go ahead and take
it back we're gonna bring it back to
computer programming I'm gonna show you
some examples of conditional statements
in a couple programming language and how
this relates and trust me as the
computer code your writing gets more
complicated a good firm solid
understanding of these logic
fundamentals are really gonna play a big
part on your ability to be calm on your
competency my next video I'm gonna do
set theory that's another very important
concept it's like the next step in logic
if you understand propositional logic
and step theory like really really well
you are going to excel at learning
whatever programming language or
techniques you're trying to learn let's
look at an example you're
friend invites you to dinner you are
only interested in going if dinner is at
a Greek restaurant right your response
using implication
now remember implication it P then Q if
not P then na q okay let's break down
this example okay - your friend invites
you to dinner that's not really
important you are only interesting going
you're gonna go if dinner is at a Greek
restaurant right you're not gonna go if
it's not at a Greek restaurant if dinner
is Greek you are gonna go if dinner is
not Greek you're not gonna go the
hypothesis is dinner is Greek that's the
P and the conclusion is I will come to
dinner you're writing your response so
if dinner is Greek your response is
gonna be I will come to dinner let P
equal Greek like Q equal I will come let
R equal I will not come if P then Q and
if not P then R and here I use this
example from my website because it
already has the rules for a conditional
statement clearly written out so I'm
going to explain now how we're gonna
transfer that into computer code okay so
this examples in PHP I'm also going to
show you with JavaScript afterwards the
way the syntax works in PHP per if
statements you write if inside the frame
to see in your condition and then inside
the brackets the clever code you want to
execute if the condition is true if it's
a save constructed on JavaScript it's
pretty common here this is where things
get a little bit different than
JavaScript but I'm gonna show you how
it's easy once you know the base logic
to write it in whatever language
if dollar sign dinner equals equals or
you could put three equals their Greek
echo in PHP echo print something yes I
will go to dinner okay so now we are
going to write this in PHP we're gonna
let people Greek q equal I will come to
dinner and are equal I will not come to
dinner so P then Q and if not P then R
so how would we write this in PHP dollar
sign P equals Greek and PHP this is how
you declare a variable you put a dollar
sign in front of it and then you know
it's a variable so dollar side P equals
Greek I put Greek in quotes because the
PHP a string that's like word sends as
characters we put them in quotes double
or single then I have dollar sign Q
equals I will come or ending each line
with a semicolon because that's how you
do it dollar sign R equals I will not
come so basically the condition is your
P and then inside is your Q if dinner
equal Greek echo I will come else what
else means is it's the opposite of
whatever condition is in here
so if in here I wrote x equals three if
x equals three this would execute and if
X didn't equal three
this would execute so else echo I will
not come see how this could be simply
translated into whatever programming
languages you're at you know you would
have to Google how do I declare a
variable what the syntax looks like but
once you get to construct the condition
is the P and the code is the Q now let's
take a look at it in JavaScript and
JavaScript instead of putting a dollar
sign we just name them whatever we want
and then
we put bar in front of it so and other
than that it's pretty much the same is
with the PHP and JavaScript we can print
to the terminal using console.log so
instead of echo I use console.log here
but those are the basic differences as
you can see in the syntax bar it's in a
dollar sign console.log instead of echo
other than that we're transferring it
the same way we put our P in here and we
put our Q in there don't forget I do
have homework in the form of a quiz game
and some reference materials available
at coding commander's comm slash logic
dot PHP on a page you'll see links to
everything I have related to here to
help you out now let's do some practice
problems together now I'm just going to
do some simple little math problems with
you using logic so you get a better
grasp on how to apply the logic to
real-life problems I definitely suggest
afterwards checking out the quiz I have
to reinforce the logic that you've
learned and also get better at it
quicker at it sharper at it good idea
would be to these examples that I'm
doing go ahead and write it out in
whatever programming language you might
be working on if you've started learning
one or if you know you want to learn one
I did also like materials odd writing
logic in PHP so if you're not already
working on a programming language go
ahead and write out my examples in PHP
if you can't think of how you can always
console.log print equals I have this
like blown up a little bit it looks a
little pixelize that's cool right pixels
are cool right so let's do x equals two
and we're gonna go ahead and do y equals
zero so let's say that x equals two is
our P and y equals zero is arc
P and Q would read that x equals two and
y equals zero so let's say if X plus y
equals four what are the truth
possibilities here okay so let's see
what are the different possibilities of
truth here
first of all okay if x equals two and y
equals zero 2 Plus 0 is 2 not 4 so
something's fishy here right would it be
possible for X and Y to both be true
would that be possible
no this one would be false would it be
possible for X or Y to be true yes this
is possible we don't have enough
information really to know anything you
know we know that one of them's lying at
least right haha one of them could be
like or both of them could be lie so
here this could be true or false we're
gonna need some more information here to
make a definite decision but if I were
to give this to you as a given this can
still be true now let's do X or could be
true or false as well right
okay now let's do this I'm gonna give
you some information and let's come up
with some stuff that's true and some
stuff that's false given X is less than
Y a parenthesis and x equals 3 so we're
gonna take this as bat now let's see I'm
gonna give you some values and you tell
me if it's true or false y equals 3 y
equals 0
why equals 3 times X okay now you tell
me what's true and what's false okay
first of all with the given it's an an
so that means both have to be satisfied
X has to be less than Y and X also has
to equal 3 so which of these statements
could Polly be true given the
information okay if X is less than Y and
X is equal to 3 can Y also be equal to 3
no if it was less than or equal to that
could be true but it's not so this is
false sure that we know that's
definitely not the case y equals 0 if X
equals 3 and Y is less than X could Y be
0 no because well 0 is less than 3 and Y
is got to be bigger than 3 false
y equals 3 X could Y be equal to the
value of x times 3 which is 9 yes
because 9 is bigger than 3 okay given
I'm gonna give you some information in
this information I'm giving you we're
gonna just assume is true x equals
negative 3 y equals 3 and Z equals 0 now
I'm gonna give you some statements and
then you tell me if they are true or not
let's do negative y is less than 0 X is
equal to Y and X plus y equals Z all
right negative Y is less than 0 okay Y
is 3 y is 3 so negative Y would be
negative
the ring and negative three is
definitely this is so true yeah you
always felt you're wrong okay I'm gonna
give it a star now let's do X equals y
if X is negative three and Y is three
those are not equal so this is ball X
plus y equals Z does negative three plus
three equals zero yes it does this is so
true yay thank you for watching my video
if you have any questions at all please
don't hesitate to comment below so I can
help you out I will be going through the
comments on this video also feel free to
reach out to me on any of my social
media at coning commander on twitter
everywhere else some coding commanders
you can just google me see where I'm at
thank you again for watching and until
next time happy coding